hello guys welcome vectors city skylines
I mean my cozen tycoon 3 and that was
the best acting I've ever heard but
seriously I am NOT going to drop this
game don't worry about that I am
definitely not going to drop this game
but city skylines is just something that
I enjoy so much right now that that is
why I'm but making videos of that but
this park is something that needs to be
finished and even if I don't like it
this is destiny and that is why I'm
actually working on this quite a bit
despite my current activity in city
skylines that is going to calm down in a
couple of days and i'm going to upload
more roller coaster taken three again
but right now i'm actually working on
finishing this park and by that i don't
just mean finishing the park itself but
also the surrounding things and that is
not the trees but rather the music and
trying to work with recording techniques
because i have a couple things to talk
about right now first of all there is
the fact that i have possibly fine found
out a way to get slow motion into roller
coast econd three now there are two ways
to do this as it turns out and there's
one easy way to do this and there's a
hard way now the easy way requires a
good and beefy computer though but
luckily i have that so the thing is you
turn up the FPS counter in roller
coaster Guthrie and record with fraps as
with as many frames as you can and I
managed to get about 70 frames per
second so if you speed that up a bit
you're gonna have a more than twice slow
down footage of roller coaster second
three without like and that was actually
a pretty cool thing to see so I might
actually use that in my roller coaster
building a hard way to do this but this
would work with slower systems as well
is to make a CTR using the exact car and
track that you're trying to record and
then place that over the existing coil
and the over existing the track I mean
and the thing with the CTR is it has to
be a CTR with a constant speed I'm going
to set that constant speed to a very
slow speed and then it's in the editing
techniques to actually get this to work
because you're gonna have to record a
very slow video of a very slow running
roller coaster and then you're gonna
speed parts up afterwards
which are going to seem like the real
parts and then the pipe that you want to
slow mo you're just going to put in real
time and then it kind of looks like a
slow-motion video as well but that that
takes a longer time and it's not as
realistic but it doesn't require a good
computer now the other thing that I've
been working on considering this Pike is
that I'm working on the music and it's
not really going that rate as in I've
plenty of inspiration for the music
itself and I spent a couple of days
trying to get the vsts then I need for
it in certain ways and you know that is
still a somewhat cool process and I'm so
far doing fine with that but when it
comes to the mastering I completely suck
at music so I that there might actually
be a chance then I'm going to be
collaborating with somebody on mastering
the music and I hope that that is
actually going to be the case and that
would be really awesome but right now
back to rolla co 2nd 3 this was a very
experimental carousel because at first i
was going to build a flat ride over here
very similar to the e-boat right that i
had going but because i wanted to have a
facade in here somehow but i also wanted
to get one more flat right now the
obvious choice would be to have a flat
right that kinda stand against of a shot
like this this is rotating vertically
singing bus that goes up and down I
didn't even know what you call those
things or the magic carpet something
like that but i already have many
swinging rides over here and many
straight facades so i decided to be
stupid and just plop down a carousel and
then see what i could do with that and
so far i'm actually not too unhappy with
the results it actually turns out to be
an okay choice to have a dome in the
middle of a facade but it's not as bad
as i expected it to be so i'm really
happy about that and with all the
details in it it's definitely going to
look awesome so yeah that's the current
state and what I'm doing with this right
now I'm thinking about adding a very
small building next to it like a low
building that I have on the side as well
because right now I already have so many
buildings about this square though I
might as well just fill up every every
little inch of space that I've left with
buildings and just get rid of foliage as
a whole because who likes foliage it's
all about the buildings
I mean seriously at this point in this
pike that is definitely the case over
here and after that the park is almost
going to be finished and I say almost
because I have no idea other that how
finish this Pike is actually because I'm
going to do the detail of bailing I
don't even know what to call Matt but
it's going around the park and looking
at small things that need to need to be
fixed or it could use some more details
or thinking whom I could actually build
a building over here and that means that
at this point after finishing this
building and its surroundings the park
is going to be quote unquote finished
but knowing me and being a perfectionist
that is not going to be the case quite
yet and it's going to be finished when I
think it is finished when I think it is
okay to leave it because a park a true
park is never finished and one of the
hardest things in roller coast again
three actually at least that's what I
find is finishing something because the
the entire time when you're building it
you're working towards that moment when
you're finishing it and you're almost
looking forward to it but then as soon
as you finish it you get the real I'd
realization that it is done and then
after that you can't do anything on it
anymore and then you start finding
things like oh I can fix this small
little detail over here or I could do
something about that and that is when
you get into the face of perfectionism
that the park is never going to be
finished and you get certain cases and I
don't know if any if but all you guys
have heard of this but there is quite an
infamous roller coaster called ashbridge
and this has turned into a kind of
inside joke of the community there was
muffins on Oct lounge and he had his
wooden coaster ashbridge and he worked
on that for four years or something like
that in any case he worked on edge
bridge for many years and that has kind
of become the example of what happens
where you don't finish something and
that is actually quite common it is
quite common that people work on roller
coasters and things like that for many
months in this bit in this game and that
still surprises me but also people from
not from this community because
sometimes people can put so much effort
into just one ride and although I am not
really a perfectionist in
that sense because I'm not really a big
fan of removing things if I don't really
like them I'd rather move on and try
something new and just let the old one
stand because one thing that is kind of
well an issue that you might encounter
when you're a perfectionist is that you
don't like your building and the rest of
the community does and then the building
is going to be deleted I used to you try
building a new building but it doesn't
come out that well I delete that as well
and there you could spend ages in the
game but essentially not really creating
anything so my advice to any
perfectionist would be if you ever make
a mistake with the building just kind of
improve it with what you have but i'm
not really a huge fan of deleting
something entirely because even though
it is a way to improve i always feel
like it's a waste of a building that
other people might actually enjoy and
that is also why i saved this building
because at some point during the during
the making of this building i thought
that this was not going to happen this
is this is not really what I want at
least that's what I figured halfway
through building this building but now
that I'm looking at it afterwards it's
not that bad but yeah I like that I let
it stand there and just try to improve
it a bit at some point I removed the
entire top part of the building and that
didn't make it a little bit better i
think which is going to happen right now
yep there it goes and I was kind of
streaming this but not entirely because
I was trying to stream actually I've
been trying to stream for the last week
but for some reason my upload speed is
below to right now and the stream
quality was definitely not good and it
was lagging so i had to stop that but
there is thankfully skype sharing so
that happened and when I removed the top
part of this building everybody was
going on no what are you doing but you
know sometimes sacrifices I need it in
this game I like I like adding removing
I mean small pieces of built of a
building and seeing if you can improve
on it in that way but removing an entire
building because I'm not too happy about
it is something i like to refrain from
doing it and if I really build a
building that is utterly terrible and I
can't seem to do anything about it then
I like to just take
nor it and kind of disregard it while
filming just film from angles that you
don't really see the building that well
or one very popular technique is to take
trees and spam them all over the front
of the building because if you have a
facade that's not that good you can take
trees and place them in front of the
facade and the facade will look somewhat
better because trees just makes
everything look more natural and good in
that sense but it also covers up the
facade and its ugliness so that is a
win-win situation so much definitely I
could definitely something I could
recommend I know that some people
actually like to do this and afterwards
they're like haha I placed all of these
trees in front of this facade and it is
obvious that they doing it to cover up
the facade and make it look less ugly
but then again it's not really a bad
thing to do and this was an experiment
it kind of like an experiment building
this is the kind of building that you
take new sets that you've really worked
with before a new objects and you try to
see if you can actually use them in this
building but thankfully something that I
was very afraid of what was going to
happen didn't happen that is
experimenting with stuff and then it
turns out that it doesn't work because
it did kind of work especially with the
sets that I used so I'm happy about that
but anyway that's this building and this
episode is all over so i'll see you guys
next time